[Applause]
my name is kiki vandaway i'm the
executive vice president of global
basketball for the mba
i went to ucla it was a fantastic
basketball school and i was very very
lucky that uh i got drafted by the nba
right out of college playing with the
denver nuggets for the portland trail
blazers and the new york knicks and i
was kind of a player coach for my last
year in the league for
the los angeles clippers and after that
ran a couple businesses then i got a
call to come and oversee basketball for
the nba and i'm in charge of the games
and everything you see on a basketball
court i was at the nba for about a year
adam silver was just taking over as the
commissioner and he really wanted me to
expand my knowledge my management skills
my leadership skills and so he said see
if there's a management program that
makes sense for you it was actually
really easy once i found out that
stanford had one
at stanford you are instructed by
nobel prize winning professors they
interact with you in a way that you
could never get any place else when you
come to eld you you come to make
yourself better and you come to
accelerate your growth curve and all
these things
are about your path and focused on that
what you get out of it is the ability to
make others better that's what i'm able
to do in my job make other players
better give them some insight make the
nba league office a bit of a better
place and bring in some new ideas that
perhaps can make not only basketball but
the way we bring basketball to our fans
around the world a better experience
i have changed rules a little bit at the
nba i was first hired as a vice
president a little bit more limited role
actually after this program i
was made the executive vice president in
charge of all the basketball i really do
think that this program had a lot to do
with that eld is is a game changer for
anybody who wants to engage and wants to
work and wants to understand and what
you need to bring to the table is a
curiosity eld exceeded every expectation
that i could potentially have had
i've recommended that anybody who wants
to not only make themselves and their
career path better but accelerate the
career path of anybody they work with
would do well to come here to an eld
program
[Music]